i'm announcing the first tranche of
sanctions these sanctions
are a major step and we hold further
sanctions at readiness to be deployed
this is about as close to global
economic war as we've ever come compared
to all historical campaigns
this is taking sanctions to the limit
the economy is tanking the ruble has
fallen through the floor inflation is
soaring
interest rates are up
the russian invasion of ukraine
triggered a global economic response
without precedent in terms of its speed
scale and scope the sanctions we imposed
have generated two thirds of the world
joining us they are profound sanctions
the european union and its partners are
working to [ __ ] putin's ability to
finance his war machine in a matter of
days the us the uk the eu and others
essentially unplugged the world's 11th
largest economy from the global economic
system we have never applied such deep
severe and far-reaching sanctions
on such a large country vladimir putin
himself has called it a declaration of
war and in economic terms he's not far
off but will this financial assault on
the russian economy actually achieve its
goal of pressuring russian president
vladimir putin to call off his troops
the big gamble right now is to see if
the west can bankrupt russia enough that
they cannot fight an insurgency moreover
what would be the consequences of this
economic war for everyday russians and
how will this conflict affect the us
economy and the lives of everyday
americans
in 1990 just months after the fall of
the berlin wall russia's first
mcdonald's opened in moscow a sign that
the nation was joining the global
economy
but on march 8th of this year the chain
announced that it would be closing all
of its restaurants in russia temporarily
it definitely feels like a new iron
curtain is coming down between east and
west i mean back during the cold war it
was taken for granted that still get
blocked in the western bloc we did not
trade with each other and we're in some
sense returning to that world the first
move was made by western governments
when they targeted russia's banking
system by blocking the russian central
bank from selling its foreign currency
reserves we will stop putin from using
his war chest perhaps the most severe
impact has been the seizing of the
assets of the central bank of russia
basically putin put away a lot of money
for a rainy day to help him weather the
storms of future sanctions episodes
sanctions sent the value of the ruble to
an all-time low against the dollar
prices for russia's most important
exports like natural gas nickel and
wheat shot up to record highs the u.s
the eu the uk and canada removed some
russian banks from swift the financial
messaging network used by banks across
the globe additional sanctions included
blacklisting russia's biggest banks from
the global financial system legislation
to freeze russian oligarch wealth abroad
this is not an economic crime bill it's
an economic warfare bill and export
restrictions for certain technologies
we estimate that we'll cut off more than
half of russia's high-tech imports this
economic war may have begun with
government sanctions but as the conflict
has continued private companies and
investors have begun to voluntarily
sever ties with russia many western
companies without being forced to are
simply you know packing up and leaving
russia we're seeing um even though in
theory russian oil and gas is exempt
from sanctions many uh
market participants simply don't want to
do business with russian oil and gas
some western companies decided to
suspend operations in russia while
others decided to pull out entirely
economic
for everyday russians the sanctions can
be seen in emptier shops as foreign
brands and businesses pause their
operations or exit the country entirely
there's also bank runs as those with
deposits in foreign currency rush to
take it out or convert their rules to
dollars to protect the value of their
savings imagine that you had a bank
account full of money and you said well
there's all the money i need to buy my
groceries put gas in my car to pay my
mortgage bill and then one day the
government said i'm sorry you have all
that money but we're not going to let
you access what's going to happen well
you're going to starve your car's going
to run out of gas and you're going to
default on your mortgage and that is
more or less what's happening to russia
on kind of a macro scale russian bond
prices also sank the country's dollar
denominated sovereign bonds were quoted
at around 17 cents on the dollar on
march 2nd down from 95 cents the
previous week
it is more or less less being shoved
into the financial equivalent of the
stone age you'll see over the coming
weeks that a global economy a western
oriented economy a relatively well-off
middle-class economy is going to see its
livelihood what be wiped out although
russia will bear the brunt of these
sanctions their impact is already being
felt across the world you don't cut
yourself off from one of the world's
largest exporters of oil and gas and
other valuable commodities overnight and
expect there to be no effect this month
the price for brent crude oil hit a
record high
today i'm announcing the united states
is targeting the main artery of russia's
economy the binding administration
banned the import of russian oil though
the u.s only imports about eight percent
of its oil from russia
russia produces 11 of global oil and
possesses 25 of the world's natural gas
reserves so cutting those resources off
from the global economy is unlikely to
happen overnight
that's especially true for russia's
biggest natural gas customer europe
which relies on russia for about 40 of
its natural gas and that's the big
question mark who's going to touch gas
first it's a third rail will europe do
it and say we're gonna we're gonna take
the economic costs no matter what putin
could
preempt that and and stop
shipments of oil and gas to europe
that would have a dramatic impact on
european economies
but it would also mean that that no
money is flowing or hardly any money is
flowing into russia anymore russia is
also the world's largest exporter of
wheat a major exporter of coal and one
of the top producers of metals and
fertilizer
how are we going to replace that grain
right how are we going to make sure that
north africa and the middle east don't
starve as a result of this sanctions are
supposed to compel a country to change
its behavior but some experts say these
economic tools don't always accomplish
their goals i think it could backfire
yeah julia friedlander says historically
they've rarely forced the targeted
country to change its behavior if your
goal is to stop a war to stop putin from
flattening ukraine using financial means
then you may lose putin tomorrow could
flatten ukraine through aerial
bombardment and then sanctions would
have meant nothing we might come to see
that these sanctions were not worth it
that all of the effort that we expended
actually caused more crisis than we had
reckoned with
[Music]
in some cases sanctions have hastened
global conflict rather than ending it if
you go back in history you can find the
sanctions or oil embargo against japan
pushed the japanese regime into a corner
and led them to respond militarily
and we got pearl harbor on march 16th
fed chairman jerome powell announced
that the central bank would be hiking
interest rates to curb rising inflation
which is being exacerbated by the war
the surge in prices of crude oil and
other commodities that resulted from
russia's invasion of ukraine
will put additional upward pressure on
near-term inflation here at home the
american government can take steps
to help manage
and assuage some of the uh
pain that is being felt by those that
are affected most directly
by the increased energy costs right now
there is extraordinary support across
the west for uh these sanctions and for
the ukrainian people it is not clear
that six months from now after a period
of very painful painfully high prices
and perhaps weaker economic growth but
that support will still be there